first off get your pan on wrist and
stock start off with this amazing
fermented soy bean puree into the pan
three nice tablespoons gas on now get
your fish stock and whisk into the puree
be generous with the stock you want this
nice light broth basically you can buy
miso paste from big supermarkets and it
works brilliantly with salmon poaching
the salmon in the me system gives it a
really nice sort of sweet earthy creamy
flavor
it's incredible to bring up to the ball
could infuse the broth and make a little
bit more fragrant
kaffir lime leaf is bay lemonade in size
the miso broth then chopped chili
chilies in and finely sliced ginger
that's simmering beautifully that will
post the salmon poaching means cooking
in liquid those cook gently and the
secret here is to keep that a salmon
skin on if we took the skin off now the
salmon will actually break up whilst is
poaching skin side down just going to
slide that in under nice
the minute that stop start boiling turn
it down let it simmer take a little
ladle and just every couple of minutes
pour over that makes sure the top of a
salmon is cooked evenly and then keeps
it nice and moist and poaching is one of
the most delicate ways of cooking so you
have to handle it with care whilst the
salmon poaching and the miso broth start
preparing your vegetables I'm using
tender stem broccoli and bok choy
I was like to cook the leaf and the stem
separately the leaf is like sort of
spinach and the stem is so much bigger
has almost as thick as a stick of celery
so I like to get the stems sliced it
just sounds like that nice full of
Christmas place the leaves together
nicely roll them up nice and tight and
then slice them down now a salad already
the flavor in that broth has been
elevated now it tastes really fishy got
the heat the chili spices the ginger and
the kaffir lime leaf take your fish
slice and place it very gently
underneath the salmon and push it down
fish slices are flexible for that reason
bend it lift it up just touch it open
for a springy firm texture just sit on
top little touch other broth over it
it stops it from drying out leave that
to cool down for two minutes bring the
stock back up to the boil broccoli in
bak choy stems in little taste see it
better and better and better cook the
broccoli and the Doctore stems for one
minute and then add the tops in
turn the summer into your hand just peel
the skin off the skin also helps to keep
the Sun a nice and moist
then gently flake the salmon that's the
secret behind poaching everything just
stays so moist wonderful long shards of
pink now just before we serve we're
gonna add our mushrooms these are enoki
mushrooms you could buy these in Turkey
mushrooms in big supermarkets and good
grocers slice them off and put half in
and the other half and I serve with the
salmon toasted sesame seed oil a little
drip in there just rub and you're just
lining almost like a little coat of
varnish start off with your mushrooms
and then my salmon for nice layers and
then finally the mushrooms top with the
vegetables and then finally a nice label
that beautiful really sumptuous rich
stock
lovely and there's an amazing
misoo poached salmon soup simplify your
cooking by getting organized and amazing
food will be coming out your kitchen
every day and for great food you need
great ingredients as it just gives that
scrunch nicely
I could feed you a different fish 365
days